can we walk through this for a second
now you've seen this before I wonder if
you remember we drew out this really big
table it had like I think I had four
columns and six rows and we said okay
you've got a mortgage how much is going
to be owing on to six months of on
interest getting charged you repay and
then they charge more interest and then
you pay some more that's what's
happening here do remember the tug of
war between interest and repayment now
what I've done is I made this question
what charging because I put at the end I
want to see if you understood what was
going on because it's obviously a lot
easy to fill in a table versus to think
about what's happening the questions
quite like jam-packed of information and
you can see from there that there are
two basic things happening there is an
interest rate that gets charged that
means that the principle that you're
owing it's going to get bigger and
bigger and bigger unless you do
something about it
and there's something that you're going
to do is this monthly payment okay now
you can think back in your mind okay if
there's going to be interest charged and
a repayment that makes the principal low
on the balance lower which do you think
is going to happen first are they going
to charge you interest or are you going
to impact they're always going to charge
you interest you're gonna say oh that's
cool I'll just pay a day earlier and
they'll say hahaha
joke's on you we'll just charge an
interest bearing up why would they do
that because if they charge interest
while your principle is still larger
they charge you more interest right so
that's how you know interest always
comes first
okay so there's my principle I'm only
looking the first month right so I've
got 1 months of interest do you see
what's going on they're coming just zoom
into them there is my 1 month of
interest so you see is now we're doing 2
months then next I've got to go through
this whole process because the repayment
is happening which I haven't calculated
yet so why is this divided by 12 what's
that about
it's monthly that's per annum and this
is per month it's one biggest one month
is past and your calculator will give
you this number but then after they
charge interest
woopsy days me after they've charged
interest then you make your repayment
and visit the balance ok the balance is
at the end of the first month both those
things are happens this is how much I
questions
I'd be interested to see how you did it
generally speaking just as an overall
principle if you take a mathematically
sound approach and you arrive at the
correct answer
generally speaking big thumbs up however
I'm saying generally speaking because
just important we know this right and
bang this drum so much just so important
is this final number if not more
important is actually how you got there
and it needs to be clearly communicated
you guaranteed this question is gonna be
worth at least two marks because they're
looking at how you do right so I guess
I'd have to look individually to see but
yes long as it makes sense of you've got
a balance aren't you're in a good
position just like does anyone want to
ask questions about the 319 figure what
can we move on
last question look okay so this is the
most recent thing that we looked at
under credit and borrowing this is
present and future values now the
question didn't say present or future
value but how did I know that was
present future value okay they're very
good you can see it's talking about now
and then you know repay in the future
you've got five years to do this there's
another signal by the way in case you
didn't spot that one what's the other
signal that tells you this was something
there's something else hold on with you
here let me come back to question one
come back to question one what was the
cue that told me what language told me
was simple interest it was the words
flat rate loan do you remember that flat
rate one flat rate means simple interest
well when you come over to hear the
language that tells me I'm following the
language that tells me wrong question
present future value is that unlike a
flat rate learning president future
values always on compound interest rates
always on contactors in fact you could
have just used the compound interest
formula on your read
from industry because you guys know it's
the same formula just relabeled over
there okay so I've done this in two
parts
do you remember why do I bother to do it
in two parts yeah okay so I can see I've
changed the time you can do this all in
one if you like but I really like doing
this right because yeah that's why I can
find out I can trace back right so I
worked out the number of months which is
considered like the same as the early
Christian the interest per month so I
divide by 12 and then these are the
numbers that I fit into you can see on
the right hand side of quoted if these
are the others I fit into my present and
future value formula how did I know she
used this one and not the other one
yeah yeah that's right the question
giorgia I stayed young be able to finish
the screen up
the way I knew is because the question
is asking you that is this is something
you know so you don't want that is the
subject I mean if you chose the wrong
formula you can still work it out it's
just slower
that's my figure common sense check this
number is smaller than the one who can
3,000 the question is it supposed to be
smaller it is because this amount is
gonna grow and then I'm gonna repay my
loan yeah absolutely you can take this
pick up put it into like the compound
interest formula you can put it into
this right with the internship where you
worked out and 60 months and out should
pop out 120 thousand dollars okay it'll
be slightly off cuz you've rounded it
might be a bit more money than less but
you get the idea